ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
HUESO OUR TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
HAMBURG.
Y. CASKEY WIENER WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
LET US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
YESTERDAY WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
NINETIETH BIRTHDAY OF AND FRANK.
IN HER DIARY SHE SAYS.
I KEEP MY IDEALS BECAUSE IN
SPITE OF EVERYTHING.
I STILL BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE ARE
REALLY GOOD AT HEART.
I SIMPLY CAN'T BUILD UP MY HOPES
ON A FOUNDATION.
CONSISTING OF CONFUSION MISERY
AND DEATH.
GOD OF HOPE AND GOODNESS.
GRANT US THE GRACE TO BE ALERT
TO THE DAILY CHALLENGES TO ALL
THAT IS GOOD AND OUR HEARTS.
MAY WE LISTEN TO AND LEARN FROM.
THE VOICES AND WISDOM OF THE
YOUNG.
AND LIVING UP TO OUR IDEALS MAY
REFUSE TO BE UNDERMINED OR
DISSUADED.
FROM BRINGING PEACE LOVE AND
JUSTICE TO OUR WORLDS.
BY THOSE WHO WOULD SPREAD
DISSENSION INTO.
AND SO WE SAY ST AND FRANK PRAY
FOR US AMEN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SO TO PUBLIC.
HI -- THIS IS ALSO.
FOR THE GOOD SERVICE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE TO RISE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN
THE MAD THE LOUNGE.
VERY GOOD MEMBERS ARE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE.
SENATOR BATES FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE.
OKAY.
THE DEBATES FOR A PURPOSE TO
RISE YES REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN
THE LOUNGE VERY GOOD IT WILL BE
A REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE ****
LOUNGE.
CORRECTION I IT WILL BE IN THE
LEADER'S OFFICE.
PUBLICANS YOU HAVE A CAUCUS IN
LEADER GROVES OFFICE RIGHT NOW
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MEDI
LOUNGE
WE ARE BACK AND READY TO
GO MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND FILE SECOND READING FILE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY
FOURTH THE MOMENTS SIX EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY
THREE WAY WITH AMENDMENTS.
THIRTY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENTS TO
LEVEL AT THE MOMENT ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SECOND READING FILE
WILL BE DEEMED READ THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO SENATE
THIRD READING ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR RUBIO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO
IMMIGRANT HERITAGE MONTH.
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
S. R. FORTY SIX WHICH PUT
PROCLAIMS THE MONTH OF JUNE.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS IMMIGRANT
HERITAGE MONTH I WANT TO THANK
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS OF LOS ANGELES
FOR SPONSORING THIS RESOLUTION.
OUR NATION IS CULTURALLY ENRICH
WITH THE STRONG PRESENCE OF
IMMIGRANTS.
IMMIGRANTS MAKE UP 42% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
IMMIGRANTS ALSO CONTRIBUTE A
TOTAL OF TWO SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTEEN BILLION WHEN IT COMES TO
CALIFORNIA'S GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCTS.
MEANWHILE IMMIGRANTS ALSO PAY
TWENTY SIX POINT FOUR BILLION IN
BOTH STATE.
AND LOCAL TAXES DESPITE THE
COUNTLESS CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY
IMMIGRANTS THEY HAVE BEEN
FREQUENTLY OVERLOOKED AND UNDER
VALUED THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
AS I SHARED WITH MANY MEMBERS I
TOO AM AN IMMIGRANT.
AND I'M I STAND BEFORE YOU AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE WITH
IMMIGRANTS ARE GIVEN
OPPORTUNITIES EDUCATION STABLE
ENVIRONMENT.
AT THAT HEALTH CARE SO I URGE MY
MY MEMBER MEMBERS TO JOIN ME.
AS I AM A PROUD AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY IMMIGRANTS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
SENATOR MAROC.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS
ALSO IS A PROUD IMMIGRANT I AM
HAPPY TO SUPPORT SR FORTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCK ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ.
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
YES NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO.
HI ROB [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBERG BARBARA COUNTY BY
WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
WIENER AYE WILK AYE.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE ARE NOW STILL UNDER
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE ARE MOVING TO OUR CONFERENCE
REPORT.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
ITEM FORTY ONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM.
AND ACTUALLY IN THE STATE BUDGET
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BUDGET BILL CENTER MITCHELL.
COLLEAGUES TODAY'S THE BIG DAY.
THIS IS AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THE ACTUAL BUDGET
BILL.
IT'S THE SPENDING PLAN FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S THE SPENDING PLAN THAT IS
INFORMED AND FUELED BY AND
FUNDED BY ALL OF OUR HARD
WORKING CONSTITUENTS.
WHO IN TRUST US WITH THE
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY? TO
SPEND THEIR MONEY WISELY
[inaudible]
CAUTIOUSLY INAPPROPRIATELY AND
SO I AM PROUD TO STAND BEFORE
YOU AND BRING BEFORE YOU FOR A
VOTE TODAY.
AB.
SEVENTY FOUR IT'S OUR BUDGET
BILL FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND IS
THE RESULT OF OVER.
SEVENTY BUDGET COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS OVER THE PAST
SIX MONTHS AS WELL AS
NEGOTIATIONS.
WITH THE ASSEMBLY AND
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT DOCUMENT ACCOUNTS FOR
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
HOURS.
BOB DISCUSSION DEBATE
COMPROMISED AND ULTIMATELY
AGREEMENT.
AND I'M PROUD TO STAND BEFORE
YOU AS YOUR BUDGET CHAIR TO
PRESENT IT TO YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
AS YOU'RE AWARE THE BUDGET
TYPICALLY INCLUDES MULTIPLE
BILLS IN TRAILERS.
AND SO TODAY WE ARE BUT VOTING
ON THE BUDGET BELT IN CHIEF AT
NEXT WEEK TRAILER IS AN
ADDITIONAL -- BILLS WILL BE
BEFORE YOU -- THAT SUPPORT IN
AUGMENT.
THE OPERATIONS IN THE DELIVERY
OF SERVICES THAT THE BUDGET BILL
IN CHIEF DETAILS TODAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DECIDED TO RUN
FOR OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
IT WAS A VERY DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A TIME WHEN -- CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS COULDN'T COUNT ON A
JUNE FIFTEENTH BUDGET.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAD A TWO THIRDS
VOTE IN REQUIREMENTS.
WE WERE IN A DEEP DEEP RECESSION.
AND CALIFORNIANS HURT AS A
RESULT OF THOSE PROTRACTED
NEGOTIATIONS I WAS RUNNING A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND WE
DIDN'T GET ARE PAID OUR CHECKS
FROM THE STATE.
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WOULD
WITHOUT I WAS IN A POSITION AS
AN EMPLOYER TO DECIDE IF I
TAPPED INTO.
THE RESERVES OF MY NONPROFIT TO
MAKE PAYROLL OR NOT. FOR MANY OF
US REMEMBER THOSE EXPERIENCES
WHEN THE STATE WAS IN DEEP
RECESSION AND TRAGICALLY WE HAD
TO CUT CRITICAL LIFE SUSTAINING.
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WE CUT DEEP INTO QUE FEW TWELVE
EDUCATION WE COULD HAVE BILLION
DOLLARS OUT EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION OUR C. ISSUES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND UC'S ARE
STILL TRYING TO CATCH UP.
FROM THE CUTS THE EXPERIENCE.
WE CUT MEDI CAL SO DEEPLY THAT
WE LIMITED THE NUMBER OF DOCTOR
VISITS A MEDICARE RECIPIENT
COULD HAVE PER MONTH.
WE ELIMINATED LIFE SUSTAINING
AND SAVING SERVICES.
WHAT COLLEAGUES I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO SAY WE ARE
NO LONGER IN THAT SPACE AS A
STATE?
AND WE ALL SHOULD BE VERY PROUD
OF THE PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE.
FOSTERED.
WITH THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BRING FOR THE
BUDGET TODAY THAT'S VERY
DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS TEN YEARS
AGO.
A BUDGET THAT I CAN SAY AS YOU
CAST YOUR VOTE TODAY.
ALL OF US CAN BE PROUD OF CAN GO
BACK TO OUR DISTRICTS AND BE
PROUD TO TALK ABOUT IT WITH
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
AND LOOK OURSELVES IN THE MIRROR
AND SAY TODAY WE DID A GOOD
THING AS SITTING MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
SO AGAIN TODAY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE FINAL
AGREEMENT.
THAT WILL DO.
MANY GOOD THINGS BUT HERE ARE
SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
IT WILL STRENGTHEN THE MIDDLE
CLASS WITH FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION AND SMALL BUSINESS
TAX CUTS.
BY THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF SCHOOL
FUNDING IN STATE HISTORY.
WILL INCREASE ENROLLMENT WE WILL
INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
SO SOME OF OUR LITTLE OF
CALIFORNIANS BY EXPANDING SEATS
IN THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
THE CHILD CARE SECTOR.
AND TO OUR FUTURE LEADERS BY
INCREASING ENROLLMENT IN C.
ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE.
WE WILL LOWER HEALTHCARE COSTS
FOR MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE PROVIDING NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND THE SERVICES THEY RENDER FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
WE ARE LOWERING TAXES FOR LOWER
INCOME CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
IMPROVING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
AND FINALLY WE DEDICATE AREN'T
WE DEDICATE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER WITHOUT ANY MIDDLE CLASS
TAX INCREASES.
FINALLY THE BUDGET DEAL WILL
RETAIN THE STATE'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO FISCAL PRUDENCE
INSTABILITY.
WITH ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS TO
RETIRE BUDGETARY DEBT.
AND HISTORIC RESERVE LEVELS.
WE'VE SET OURSELVES IN THE STATE
ON THE PATH.
THAT WOULD NOT BEEN ON BEFORE
HISTORICALLY WHERE WE WERE
VICTIMS OF AN ECONOMY THAT EBBS
AND FLOWS.
AND THEREFORE STATE INVESTMENT
AND SPENDING THAT EBBED AND
FLOWED WE NOW HEALTH SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS IMAGINE THAT.
WE WILL HELP PROTECT THE GENERAL
FUND AND PROTECT THE SERVICES
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS NEEDS.
IN THE EVENT OF A FUTURE
RECESSION.
THAT YOU SHOULD BE PROUD OF SO
AGAIN COLLEAGUES THIS BUDGET IS
BOLD [inaudible]
AND RESPONSIBLE.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE WITHIN THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR PERIOD BEFORE
JUNE FIFTEENTH.
AND SO NO ADDITIONAL CHANGES ARE
ABLE TO BE MADE TO THIS BUDGET.
TO MEET THAT REQUIRED DEADLINE
SO WE ARE VOTING ON THE BUDGET
IN CHIEF TODAY.
WE ALL KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL
NEGOTIATIONS ARE OCCURRING
BETWEEN THE THREE PRINCIPAL
PARTIES ARE LEADER HERE IN THE
SENATE.
THE LEADER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE ADMINISTRATION -- BUT I AM
CONFIDENT IN THESE ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS AND NOW THAT AS WE
LOOK AT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
NEXT WEEK.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LOW INCOME
OR MIDDLE INCOME AND FOR SOME
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS ARE GOING TO BENEFIT.
FROM THE FRUIT OF OUR COLLECTIVE
LABOR THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
GENERAL FUND THAT IS HEALTHY.
AND REFLECTS THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
AS OUR LEADER IS WORKING HARD TO
COMPLETE THE FINAL THREE PARTY
DEAL I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE
BACK HERE VOTED IN THE REST OF
THE BUDGET DEAL.
THOSE ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILLS
VERY VERY SOME SOON.
HOWEVER THE WORK TO FINALIZE THE
DEAL WILL CONTINUE THROUGH THE
WEEKEND.
BUT TODAY COLLEAGUES WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO VOTE ON THE
BUDGET BILL IN SHE THAT REFLECTS
HOURS OF WORK IN DEDICATED
SERVICE REFLECTS THE TRUE VALUES
REFLECTED IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS BY ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES I ASKED AN I BOTH.
OF AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LAYS GENTLEMAN
THE SENATE I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENCE WITH THE KNOWLEDGE ONE
OF OUR BUDGET CHAIR OF THE GOOD
CENTER OF LOS ANGELES.
IT'S A PLEASURE WORKING WITH HER
AND STORING THE BUDGET THROUGH
THESE LONG AND LABORIOUS
HEARINGS AND MONTHS OF
DELIBERATIONS.
AND THE INTERESTING THING THOUGH
OF THIS INSTITUTION IS OFTEN
ACCUSED OF SO MUCH PARTISANSHIP.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS YOU REALLY
DON'T SEE THAT SO MUCH.
MOST OF THE VOTES ARE BI
PARTISAN.
IN THE DEBATE THE DISCUSSIONS
ARE ALL RESPECTFUL AMICABLE.
AND THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
ALSO.
AND WE NOW ARE APPROACHING
[inaudible]
THE RESOLUTION.
THERE'S MUCH GOOD IN THIS BUDGET.
THE YEAR BEGAN WITH A VERY
HEALTHY [inaudible]
SURPLUS.
A RARITY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PRODUCT OF PRUDENCE.
BUT THE FORMER LEGISLATURE'S IN.
THE FORMER GOVERNOR.
THAT WAS ALLOWING US
[inaudible] TO ACCRUE
[inaudible]
THAT SURPLUS.
ASSISTED ALSO BUY SOMETHING THE
VOTERS DID.
PROPOSITION TWO THE RAINY DAY
FUND.
WHICH INSURES HELP.
AND ABOUT FOR FOR THE FUTURE.
THE GOOD IN THIS BUDGET IS.
A CONTINUING AND A STANDARD
ATTEMPT. TO DEBT RETIRE.
MORE MONEY HAS BEEN PUT FORTH
FOR THOSE PURPOSES [inaudible]
LONG NEEDED.
AND IT SHOWS THAT WE ARE SEATED
SPIRITUALLY ADDRESSING
[inaudible]
THOSE CONCERNS.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH THERE ARE
RAISING OF TAXES.
INCLUDED IN THIS.
AND THE BIGGEST DEFICIENCY.
IS THE PRECARIOUSNESS AS WE
APPROACH THE FUTURE.
DURING A PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAD A TEMPORARY BUDGET
SURPLUS I BELIEVE WAS FIFTEEN
BILLION.
THAT ALL GOT SPENT IN MORE.
AND EVEN REPUBLICANS CONTRIBUTED.
TO THE DOWNFALL OF THAT
PARTICULAR [inaudible]
YEARS SPENDING.
WELL ALL OF A SUDDEN THE ECONOMY
SO OFTEN [inaudible]
BLOCK.
WE WERE FIFTEEN BILLION AND THEN
LATER FORTY FIVE BILLION IN THE
RED.
A HUGE HOLE [inaudible] TO
ENCOUNTER.
AND TO YET AGAIN.
CRAWL OUT OF AND THE SOLUTION
CANNOT ALWAYS BE.
JUST RAISE TAXES.
IN FACT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
THIS BUDGET AS WITH OTHERS
[inaudible]
TROUBLED AGENCIES [inaudible]
LIKE DMV [inaudible]
AND ARE.
I TT PROJECTS WHICH ALWAYS RUN
BILLIONS OVER COST.
AND NEVER EVEN CLOSE TO BEING ON
TIME AND USUALLY STILL DON'T
WORK.
WELL WE ARE REWARDING THEM WITH
MORE MONEY.
ANOTHER AGENCY THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO GET GUNS AWAY FROM
[inaudible]
DANGEROUS FELONS.
HAD BEEN GIVEN A LOT OF MONEY.
AND NOTHING HAPPENED.
AN ATTEMPT HAS BEEN MADE IN THIS
BUDGET TO SEE SOME OF THAT
AUTHORITY NOW.
RIGHTEOUSLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT THEY CAN
DO THE JOB BUT NOT SUFFICIENTLY.
SO THE ANSWER ALWAYS ISN'T
SIMPLY[inaudible]
MORE MONEY.
BUT TO I FUNDAMENTAL POINT.
I DO NOT CLAIM TO BE AN
ECONOMIST I STUDY ECONOMY A LOT.
BUT I DO BELIEVE AND HAVE SAID
FOR YEARS ARE VERY BUDGET IS
PRECARIOUSLY [inaudible]
BALANCE [inaudible]
IN ANOTHER.
RECESSION.
OF ANY SORT.
NOT EVEN ONE AS SEVERE AS THE
ONE WE EXPERIENCED A FEW YEARS
BACK.
AND WE'RE GONNA QUICKLY BE
UPSIDE DOWN SO THE CAUTION THAT
I PREACHED ALL YEAR IN THIS
BUDGET THE LIBERATION
[inaudible]
USE CARE [inaudible]
CON CUIDADO [inaudible]
USE CARE.
AND BE PRUDENT CONTINUE TO BE
PRUDENT.
AND DON'T GET ENTHUSED ABOUT
BASS BUILDINGS SPENDING.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
DEFICIENCIES IN THE BILL.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
A BASE BUILDING OBLIGATIONS.
CONTAINED IN THIS BUDGET.
THAT I FEAR.
BUT TO GET US IN TROUBLE.
ANOTHER AS AN ASIDE PHENOMENA
THAT I'M STARTING TO SEE MORE
REGULARLY AND BILLS AROUND HERE
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
BILLS IT SHOULD HAVE
APPROPRIATIONS IN THEM
[inaudible]
OUR PASSING [inaudible]
POLICY BILLS.
THE CREATE FISCAL OBLIGATIONS
[inaudible]
BUT THE LANGUAGE STATES THAT
THIS WILL BE FUNDED IN FUTURE
BUDGETS.
OBLIGING FUTURE LEGISLATORS NOW
WHY WOULD THAT BE A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOT CREATED A
CONSTITUENCY IN AN EXPECTATION.
OF SOME BODY OR SOME ENTITY OR
SOME PROGRAM.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET SOME
MONEY.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEN THAT
FUTURE BUDGET.
THERE WILL BE.
DIFFICULTIES OF COURSE.
AND THIS BUDGET DOES INDEED.
BUILD FUTURE OBLIGATIONS.
BUT I BELIEVE ARE OF GREAT
CONCERN.
ENHANCE MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO
VOTE NO ON THE BUDGET. FOR THAT
REASON LOOKING FORWARD.
AND ONE OF THE GREAT
DEFICIENCIES OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
TODAY AND THIS ONE IS.
ONE WE'RE KIND OF ME NOW MAY
FIRST.
AND WE DON'T LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
WHAT WILL THIS MEAN FIVE YEARS
FROM NOW?
NOT THIS YEAR AND THEN THE OFF
YOUR BUDGET BUT WHAT WILL IT
MEAN FIVE YEARS FROM NOW AND
THIS IS MY CONCERN.
AND THAT'S WHY AS FAR AS THIS
BUDGET IS CONCERNED.
I WILL BE A NO VOTE.
AS WE DELIBERATE ON THE TRAILER
BILLS.
I BELIEVE SOME OF THOSE SO WILL
BE OF MERIT.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
QUICKLY RISE.
TO ASK FOR ALL VOTE ON THIS
ISSUE I WAS ONE OF THOSE
LEGISLATIVE WHO WERE HERE. TEN
YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE IN A
MAJOR FINANCIAL CRISIS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DEFICIT.
AND WE CUT TREMENDOUS PROGRAMS
AS OUR BUDGET YEAR CLEARLY
STATED I WANT TO COMMEND OUR
BUDGET YEAR FOR HER GREAT WORK
ON THIS -- BUDGET ARE PROTEOME
AND ALL THE CONFEREES ARE SUB
CHEERS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
BECAUSE THIS IS A BUDGET WE ALL
SHOULD BE PROUD UP.
IT'S ONE THAT RESTORES MANY OF
THE CUTS WE MAY TEN YEARS AGO SO
THE INCREASE SPENDING IS NOT
SPLURGING IT'S RESTORING MANY OF
THOSE CUTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS EDUCATION THAT WE STILL.
HAVEN'T FULLY FUNDED BACK TO ITS
ORIGINAL STATE TODAY.
SO WE THERE'S PLENTY HERE WE
SHOULD ALL BE PROUD OF REGARD
WHAT REGARDS A DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC.
BIG A REPUBLICAN IT REGARDS A
WAR YOU RESIDE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE'S BENEFITS FOR
ALL OF US WE AS LEGISLATORS HAVE
NINETY NINE PROBLEMS.
BUT THIS BUDGET EIGHT ONE I ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT --
TO BUT YOU KNOW THAT IT WAS AN
HONOR TO SERVE ON THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT THE CHAIR OF BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW.
HAS DONE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
I ALSO AS A SIDE BAR HAVE TO
THINK DOCTOR JANICE CHAO DDS FOR
LETTING ME RESCHEDULE MY FIRST
ROOT CANAL.
SO I WILL FIND OUT SOON WHICH IS
MORE ARDUOUS A SERVING ON THIS
BUDGET COMMITTEE YOU'RE GETTING
A ROOT CANAL BUT REFLECTING
RECENTLY ON THE RECENT PASSING
OF A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT BY THE
NAME OF DORIS DAY -- I'VE BEEN
HUMMING.
ABOUT ONE OF OUR SONGS FOR
TRADEMARK SONGS A LOT EVERY
MORNING THE THEME I SEEM TO WAKE
UP WITH THE WITH THE LYRICS CASE
ROSTER ROCK.
BUT WHATEVER WILL BE WILL BE THE
THE FUTURE IS NOT OURS TO THE CD
CASE ROSTER -- WHATEVER WILL BE
WILL BE I CAN'T SEEM TO GET THIS
FONG OUT OF MY HEAD.
BUT WE CAN'T SEE THE FUTURE
THAT'S WHY WE USE THE SAY
SOMETHING LIKE -- HINDSIGHT IS
TWENTY TWENTY I APPRECIATE THE
CENTER FROM TO HIM -- TALKING
ABOUT THEIR WORK WILL WE BE
SEEING FIVE YEARS FROM NOW.
SO AS WE DEAL WITH THE BUDGET IN
CHIEF A WHAT DO WE SEE NOW THAT
MIGHT GIVE US INDICATIONS OF
WHAT IS COMING.
UP AHEAD WHAT IS ON THE HORIZON
AND WHAT AT LEAST ONE OF MY
SEEING THAT WOULD MAKE ME A
LITTLE.
CONCERNED.
WHAT?
A HIGH HOUSING COSTS AND PRICES
WHICH IS NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA.
CONCERN BUT IT'S A WORLDWIDE
CONCERN.
BUT RECENTLY HOUSING PRICES HAVE
BEEN INCREASING.
AT A DECREASING RATE WHICH MEANS
WE HOPE WE SHOULD BE AT THE TOP
OF THE REAL ESTATE MARKET BUT
THEN WE MIGHT.
SEE THE OTHER SIDE AS WE HAVE IN
PRIOR RECESSIONS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN WHAT'S KNOWN
AS AN INVERTED YIELD CURVE.
WHICH FOR THE LAST SIXTY YEARS
HAS BEEN A VERY RELIABLE
INDICATOR OF AN UPCOMING
RECESSION WHETHER IT'S SIX
MONTHS AHEAD OR EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AHEAD.
WE'RE ALSO NOW SEEING MORE
TRANSPARENT AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS FOR MUNICIPALITIES.
THANKS TO A RECENT GAZ BE
STATEMENT THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD.
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS
FINALLY SAID YOU NEED TO INCLUDE.
YOUR RETIREE MEDICAL.
OBLIGATIONS ON YOUR BALANCE
SHEET.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY IT TOOK UNTIL LAST
WEEK FOR CALIFORNIA TO FINALLY
RELEASED ITS CUT COMPREHENSIVE
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORT.
AND WHEN IT CAME OUT.
THE RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS THE
LIABILITY INCREASED BY FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
OUR PENSION LIABILITIES ON OUR
MOST RECENT.
FINANCIAL STATEMENT WENT UP TEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN IN ONE
YEAR.
THE UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT FOR
CALIFORNIA ROSE BY FORTY THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION. TO TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR GOVERNMENTAL
ACTIVITIES THAT'S THE HIGHEST
THE STATE HAS EVER SEEN OF A
DEFICIT WE ARE THAT FAR IN THE
WHOLE.
SO IT IS GOOD TO SEE THAT THIS
BUDGET STARTS THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT RAINY DAY FUND.
WITH FIVE HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE IT'S ZERO RIGHT NOW.
BUT THE TOTAL UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT FOR CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
ROSE BY TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
THE LAST YEAR ALONE THE DEBTS
ARE GROWING FIVE TIMES FASTER
JUST IN THIS ONE CATEGORY.
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT GREW
THEN THIS LAST YEAR BY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S JUNE THIRTEENTH AND NOT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO CITIES.
OR ITS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
IT'S NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE COMPLETED.
THEIR JUNE THIRTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CAPPERS.
AND SO WHAT NEWS WE'VE GOTTEN SO
FAR.
HAS NOT BEEN VERY ENCOURAGING.
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED ALL FIFTY
STATES EITHER TO SEE HOW WE
COMPARE.
BUT THE CAPPERS WE ARE SEEING.
ARE TELLING A DISTRUSTING STORY.
EVEN WITH A STRONG ECONOMY OUR
CITIES COUNTIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE STRUGGLING.
JUST YESTERDAY AND GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE THE CITIES
OF EMERYVILLE.
AND SCOTTS VALLEY REQUESTED TO
RAISE THEIR TRANSACTIONS AND USE
TAX ABOVE THE 2% MAXIMUM.
RESIDENTS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ARE WORRIED ABOUT AN INCREASE IN
ELECTRICITY RATES BY THEIR
UTILITY P. JEANNIE.
THE SENATE BILL NINE A ONE
COMMISSION ENCOURAGES
ESTABLISHING A LARGE FUND TO
PROVIDE A BRAXTON.
IN ASSISTING INSURANCE CARRIERS
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO VICTIMS OF FUTURE
WILDFIRE CONFLAGRATIONS.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WHERE WHERE
DOES THAT MONEY COME FROM
SPECIAL OR TALKING THIRTY FORTY
MAYBE FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS BUDGET AND THE RELATED
BUDGET BILLS WILL RAISE
CELLPHONE RATES.
IT WILL RAISE STATE DISABILITY
RATES FOR PARENTAL LEAVE
EXTENSIONS.
IT'LL RAISE INCOME TAXES BY
CHERRY PICKING TAX CONFORMITY
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THEN ABLE TO
AN ABLE TO PAY FOR AND EARNED
INCOME.
TAX INCREASE FOR MORE REFUNDS.
IT'LL.
IT'LL RAISE HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
MANDATES.
WITH THE MANDATE PENALTY TAXES --
AND IT'S LIKE ALL MY GOODNESS
FOR JUST WE'RE JUST ADDING MORE
TAXES IN YET JUST.
EARLIER THIS MONTH THE RESIDENTS.
OF A DISTRICT WITH MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION RESIDENTS THE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT VOTED
DOWN MEASURE E..
SAYING WE DON'T WANT OTHER TAX
IF.
YOU'RE NOT MANAGING YOUR MONEY
PROPERLY.
AND OUR RESIDENTS ARE ALSO GOING
TO SEE IN JUST A FEW WEEKS.
OR DAYS THEIR GAS TAX RISE AGAIN
BY FIVE POINT SIX CENTS ON JULY
FIRST.
COLLEAGUES WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE
WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY FIVE IF I
COULD USE THE WORD FORTUNATE.
WHICH WAS A TAX INCREASE
EXTENSION A PROPOSITION.
THIRTY AND WE'VE SEEN VARIOUS
IPO ATION SAYS IN SILICON VALLEY.
THAT WE'RE ENJOYING.
EXTRA REVENUES AND A SURPLUS.
AND I'M THANKFUL I AM THANKFUL
THAT THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO PUT
MORE INTO CALPERS.
AND AT THE CAL STIRS TO HELP OUR
SCHOOLS BUT WITH A BUMPER CROP.
OF BONUS SO TO SPEAK WE SHOULD
BE DOING MORE TO REDUCE OUR
DEBTS.
HE HAS A GOOD NUMBER IT SHOULD
BE HIGHER.
COLLEAGUES THE PROVERBIAL WOLVES
ARE AT THE DOOR THE LARGEST
ASSOCIATION OF STRAPPED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE SACRAMENTO CITY.
OAKLAND UNIFIED SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED IN LA UNIFIED ARE ALL
STRUGGLING AND COMMUNICATING
THAT THEY'RE HAVING EXTREME
DIFFICULTIES THEY WILL BE ON OUR
PORCH.
CITIES THAT HAVE CUT PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICES MANY BY 25%.
ARE NOW COMING AND ASKING TO
RAISE TAXES FOR SALES TAX ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE STATE MAXIMUM.
AND ELECTRICITY RATE PAYERS.
WHO WILL HAVE TO POTENTIALLY
FIND A MASSIVE OF FIRE VICTIMS
FIND ARE NERVOUS?
COUNTIES ARE ALSO BEING
STRETCHED AND STRETCHED.
NGUYEN WE'RE SAYING IF YOU DON'T.
NEGOTIATE PROPERLY WITH YOUR IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES YOU MAY
GET A PENALTY.
I PURCHASED A LOT IN THIS BUDGET
AND IT'S TRAILER BILLS THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT. ONE
OF THE INTERESTING THINGS IS
THAT THE BUDGET DOLES OUT ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN PORK.
THIS AMOUNT WAS WAS THROWN INTO
THE ELEVENTH HOUR.
SUNDAY NIGHT IT WAS SO LARGE
THAT THAT WE HAD A POOR APPROVED
ANOTHER ITEM WHERE WE HAD TO
REDUCE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FROM
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS NOW IN
THE YEARS THAT WE REDUCE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FROM WE'RE
GOING THROUGH A RECESSION AND WE
HAVE TO CUT COSTS THAT'S USUALLY
WHERE YOU ATTACK FIRST.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A RATHER
UNFORTUNATE.
INDICTMENT OF THE BUDGET.
THE FUTURE IS NOT OURS TO SEE.
WE WILL BE JUDGED HOWEVER FOR
STEPPING OUT AT THE BEGINNING OF
A NEW EXPANSION BECAUSE MAYBE
SOMEONE IS MAKING THE ECONOMY OF
THRIVING PHENOMENON THAT
CALIFORNIA'S RATING MAYBE WE ARE
AT THE BEGINNING OF SOMETHING.
THAT WILL BE SURPRISING OR MAYBE
WERE AT THE END OF A LONG
RUNNING RISING ECONOMY THAT IS
AT THE TURNING POINT. FOR
RECESSIONARY ADJUSTMENT.
WHATEVER WILL BE WILL BE.
BUT DID WE REALLY MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS AND SET
THE PROPER PRIORITIES IN THIS
BUDGET.
QUE SERA SERA.
I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE.
ON AB SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR MORLOCK SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUDGET.
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUDGET.
BUT WE CAN'T LET THE PERFECT BE
THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD.
THIS IS A GOOD STRONG BUDGET FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I DO HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS --
THOUGH WITH A PART OF THIS
BUDGET THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FINAL EXPRESS THOSE
CONCERNS IN JUST A MINUTE BUT
FIRST LET ME.
STATE MY UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
A VERY DIFFICULT JOB THAT THEY
DO IN BALANCING ALL THESE
COMPETING INTERESTS AND
PRIORITIES WITH THE LIMóN
AMOUNT OF FUNDS.
THANK YOU.
N. FOR LEADERSHIP MADAM PRO TEM
MADAM BUDGET CHAIR MAJORITY
LEADER -- YOU ALSO HAVE MY
UTMOST RESPECT AND MY SINCERE
APPRECIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
IT'S NO EASY TASK.
AND YET YEAR AFTER YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE FINISHES WITH A
BALANCED BUDGET DELIVERED ON
TIME.
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROVAL.
EVERY CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
MEMBER DESERVES OUR PRAISE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THE TIME AND
ENERGY THEY PUT IN.
THIS PROJECT THE PROJECT OUR
PRODUCT.
THIS BUDGET EXPANDS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING HISTORIC
FUNDING LEVELS FOR EDUCATION AS
THE BUDGET CHAIR INDICATED
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
UC AND CSU STUDENTS THAT ARE
CALIFORNIANS.
AND IMPROVES OUR MERCHANT SEE
PREPAREDNESS.
AND IT ACCOMPLISHES ALL OF THIS
WHILE MAINTAINING SOLID RESERVE
FUNDS AND PAYING DOWN THE WALL
OF DEATH.
THE PART THAT I FIND
DISAPPOINTING IS THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT REFLECT MUCH OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND FISCAL
PRIORITIES OF OURS SENATE BUDGET
SUB.
TO COASTAL RESILIENCY WETLAND
RESTORATION AND OTHER INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ACTION ON MITIGATION AND
RESILIENCE ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
UNDER FUNDED WE'RE SIMPLY ZEROED
OUT FROM WHAT WE APPROVED AFTER
MONTHS OF HEARING NEGOTIATIONS
IN INPUT.
NO ONE CAN DOUBT THE NEED FOR A
LARGE INVESTMENT IN SAFE AND
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
CALIFORNIANS THAT IS WHY SENATE.
BUDGET SET TO APPROVED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION IN CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FOR OUR FROM OUR
GENERAL FUND CONTINGENT ON THE
PASSAGE OF BEST.
BE.
TWO HUNDRED THE AMOUNT
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED OUT OF
THE GENERAL FUND WOULD HAVE
FREED WOULD HAVE BEEN REDUCED BY
AN AMOUNT EQUIVALENT TO ANY NEW
REVENUE ENACTED INTO LAW TO
FINANCE THE WATER FUN.
INSTEAD THE BUT THE BUDGET
SIMPLY TAKES A SIGNIFICANT BLOCK
OF MONEY AT THE G. G. R. F. YEAR
AFTER YEAR TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF SUBSTANDARD MISMANAGED WATER
SYSTEMS WITHOUT GUARANTEES THAT
THERE WILL BE WATER DISTRICT
CONSOLIDATIONS WATER DISTRICT.
CONSERVATION OR IMPROVED
PERFORMANCE.
WHEN MARK -- LEGISLATION AB
THIRTY TWO REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TV ONLY USE
REVENUES FROM THE OPTIONS OF CAP
AND TRADE FOR PROGRAMS THAT
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS TO OUR
ATMOSPHERE.
THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD CALLS
ON ALL NATIONS SEVEN NATION
STATES CITIES AND COMPANIES THE
STEP UP IN SERIOUSLY REDUCE
EMISSIONS.
IT IS CONCERNING TO ME.
THAT THIS BILL PRIORITIZES CAPEN
TREAT OPTION REVENUES IN A
MANNER THAT FURTHER WEAKENS THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUN NOW IT'SNOT THE
FIRST TIME.
THAT THIS IS HAPPEN -- BUT I'D
HOPED IT WOULD NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
MEMBERS FOR OURSELVES FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND RESPECT THE
INTEGRITY OF AB.
THIRTY TWO WE NEED TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE
TRANSFORMATIVE AND NOT
TRANSACTIONAL.
AND WE NEED TO BE.
IN OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT BODE
WELL FOR THE FUTURE GINGER F.
BUDGETS IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE TEACHER R. F. WILL BE
BROADENED TO INCLUDE OTHER USES.
BUT I WOULD CONSCIOUS BE
CAUTIOUS.
IN THAT EVERYONE AND STATE THAT
EVERYWHERE THE CARS SHOULD NOT
BE FINANCED THROUGH THIS FUN.
WE HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED YES
INSTRUCTED BY THE BY THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY THAT OUR
WINDOW IS CLOSING AND THAT WE
MAY EVEN BE AT A POINT OF NO
RETURN.
ON PERMANENT IRREVERSIBLE AND
CLIMATE CONSEQUENCES
CONSEQUENCES VERY SOON.
WE NEED TO SHOW RESTRAINT AND WE
MUST SHOW CLIMATE AMBITION.
AND LIMIT EXPENDITURE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT TRULY REDUCE LIMIT
EXPENDITURES ONLY THE PROGRAM
SEP TRULY REDUCE CO.
TWO THE FINANCE WORTHY AND NON
CARBON REDUCE AND PROGRAMS WITH
MOVIES FARTHER NOT CLOSER TO OUR
AMBITIOUS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOALS THAT WE HAVE SET.
FOR TWENTY THIRTY THE NEXUS MUST
BE CLEAR UNEQUIVOCAL AND ROBUST
BETWEEN PROGRAMS AND CARBON
REDUCTION.
I AM PROUD OF THE WORK WE
ACCOMPLISH THE SENATE.
BUDGET SUB TO THIS YEAR MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC -- WORKED TIRELESSLY
AND PUTTING TOGETHER A PLAN THAT
WE COULD HONORABLY SAY WAS A
TREMENDOUS POSITIVE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND FOR OUR COMMUNITY I WANT TO
THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND IT SATISFIED THE MANDATE SET
FORTH IN OUR CURRENT CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AB THIRTY TWO
WHICH REQUIRES US TO READ.
USE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WITH R. G. G. R. F. EXPENDITURES.
BUT DESPITE THOSE SERIOUS
CONCERNS AND MIGHT THE
RESERVATIONS I AM HERE BEFORE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THE
REASONS I'VE STATED EARLIER I
PURGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SAID A WHITE HOUSE SKI
SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS.
I TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LANDMARK IN HISTORIC BUDGET.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE OUR PRO
TEM.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SPEAKER.
OUR LEADERS WHO HAVE COME
TOGETHER ALONG WITH OUR
CONFEREES. TO SHAPE.
THE HISTORIC BUDGET.
NEVER BEFORE HAS CALIFORNIA BEEN
ABLE TO PUT SO MUCH IN RESERVE
IN ANTICIPATION.
OF THAT RAINY DAY.
WOULD IT BE A DIP.
OR A DROP WE HAVE NINETEEN
BILLION.
IN RESERVES MORE THAN THE
GENERAL FUND OF MANY SMALL
STATES AND NATIONS.
WE STILL HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS
MOVING FORWARD BUT IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PRUDENCE.
OF THIS SPENDING PLAN
[inaudible]
IT'S INVESTING.
IN PERHAPS THE GREATEST
INVESTMENT WE CAN EVER MAKE IN
YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WHERE THE PREDICTORS.
OF GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL --
ENDING UP IN OUR PRISONS.
IT HAPPENS THERE IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE'VE
INCREASED THAT INVESTMENT WE'VE
INCREASED THE INVESTMENT. TO
MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ELECTED US TO BE THE
STEWARDS OF THEIR HARD EARNED
INCOME IN TAXES TO INVEST THAT
IN A MANNER THAT BENEFITS?
OUR COMMUNITIES OUR CHILDREN ARE
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
AND A HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THAT AS A STATE WE WILL NOW BE
OFFERING RELIEF TO MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN PROVIDE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
MEMBERS THIS BUDGET THAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO PASS [inaudible]
SUPPORTS.
A STATE GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT
OF CLOSE TO THREE TRILLION
DOLLARS. TWO HUNDRED PLUS
BILLION TO SUPPORT AN ECONOMY.
OF THREE TRILLION DOLLARS MAKING
US IF WE WERE IN NATION.
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
IN THE PLANET. ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES.
IS THE LACK.
OF INCOME AND WEALTH
DISTRIBUTION IN THIS STATE AND
THIS NATION.
THIS BUDGET ALSO WORKS TO BRIDGE
THAT GAP.
BY INVESTING IN THOSE THAT WORK
IN OUR FIELDS.
THAT WORK IN OUR SERVICE
INDUSTRIES [inaudible]
THAT.
THEY'RE BACK BREAKING LABOR.
THEIR TAX CONTRIBUTIONS OUT OF
EVERY PAYCHECK.
ALSO POSITION THEM TO BE
BENEFICIARIES OF THIS BUDGET.
FOR THEIR CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS
FOR CHILDCARE IN FOR ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE.
AND I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY
THANKING AGAIN OUR LEADERS THE
PRO TEM THE SPEAKER.
AND ESPECIALLY THE GOVERNOR. FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING.
THE CHALLENGES IT OF ACHIEVING
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
MOST OF US HAVE GROWN UP IN
COMMUNITIES.
WHERE WE TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
ABILITY TO TURN ON THE TAP?
AND DRINK A GLASS OF CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
BUT CLOSE TO A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
DON'T HAVE THAT BENEFIT DON'T
HAVE THAT FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHT.
IN THIS BUDGET.
IS BOLD IN THE NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENT [inaudible] TO INVEST.
NOT IN FIVE YEARS NOT IN TEN
YEARS BUT IMMEDIATELY.
IN BRINGING RELIEF TO THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
COR INHABITED ALSO BY
CALIFORNIANS BY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS WHO IN MANY OF
THESE COMMUNITIES CAN'T DRINK
THE WATER.
THEY CAN'T DAYS WITH THE WATER.
IN A CAN'T COOK WITH THE WATER.
AND SO ON TOP OF LIMITED INCOMES.
THEY PURCHASE.
BOTTLED WATER EVERY WEEK.
SOME STILL PLAYING ALL WATER
BILL. FOR WATER THEY CAN'T USE.
SO THE LEADERSHIP NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENT TO USE OUR BUDGET TO
INVEST IN THIS IMMEDIATE RELIEF.
I WOULD SUBMIT.
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO SOME
WOULD ARGUE IT IS OVERDUE.
BUT WE WILL MAKE HISTORY TODAY
BY MAKING GOOD ON THAT PROMISE.
OF ADDRESSING THE HUMAN RIGHT OF
EVERY CALIFORNIA. FOR ACCESS TO
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
MEMBERS I URGE YOUR STRONG
YOU'RE CONFIDENT IN YOUR PROUD I
VOTE.
ON AB SEVENTY FOUR OUR BUDGET
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS.
I'M PROUD TO STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET BELL I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT MY GOOD
FRIENDS MODERATE POINTED OUT
THAT ACTUALLY THIS ENTIRE BUDGET
REPRESENTS 1% OF OUR STATE GDP.
BUT WHAT IMPORTANT 1% IT IS AND
AS CHAIR BUDGET SUB THREE I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT SOME THE ITEMS.
THE PARTICULARLY THAT WERE IN
OUR PURVIEW.
THAT WE ARE MOVING FORWARD FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
REALLY ADDRESSING BOTH THE NEEDS
OF THE PEOPLE BUT ALSO AND I
APPRECIATE THE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SAY WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
HOW WE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE HOW
YOU'RE MAKING?
CHOICES THAT WILL HELP US AS OUR
ECONOMY NEWS ON AND OUR IS OUR
STATE MOVES FORWARD BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO FUTURE.
CASE ROSS ROCK -- BUT WE CAN
PLAN FOR IT AND WE CAN WE SHOULD
TAKE Y. STEPS TO ADDRESS THAT.
THE WORST OF THE THINGS WE'RE
DOING IN THIS BUDGET -- IN THE
REALM OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO HELP THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIAN INVEST IN THE FUTURE.
WELL WE HERE AND WE KNOW IN THE
LAST ELECTION -- IN THE PP I SEE
POLL SHOWS THAT HEALTHCARE WAS A
MAJOR ISSUE.
PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT
HEALTHCARE COSTS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
PROVIDING RELIEF IN THIS BUDGET --
WE'RE PROVIDING RELIEF BY
ACTUALLY HELPING.
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES FAMILIES
OF FOUR WITH INCOMES UP 210050% --
AND UP TO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND I SHOULD SAY UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND OF INCOME WILL BE
GETTING ASSISTANCE OUT TO HELP
PURCHASE INSURANCE ON COVERED
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO GONNA BE TAKING SOME
POLY STATUS THE STEPS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY HELP [inaudible]
REDUCE THE THE PROJECTED
INCREASE AND IT AND AN
INTERESTING IS BY 325% AS WELL.
AND SO WE'RE MAKING SMART
CHOICES TO HELP REDUCE THE
FUTURE SPENDING NOW CERTAINLY
AGING WE TALK OFTEN ABOUT THE
SILVER TSUNAMI WE'RE MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN PLANNING FOR
AGING THE FACT THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED MORE LONG TERM -- SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SO WE'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
THAT REGARD AS WELL.
I KNOW THAT HELPING PEOPLE
DISABILITIES WAS SOMETHING THAT
HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH NOW
YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE BUT CROSS THE
BUDGET AND HOPEFULLY IN THE I
BELIEVE IN THIS CHAMBER.
AND WE ARE PROVIDING INCREASED
PAYMENTS TO IMPROVE ACCESS.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT -
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE ACTUALLY
INVESTING TO IMPROVE OUR CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM TO BE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPPORTING THEIR
CHILDREN ARE PAYING INTO THAT
THE STATE THAT HAVE TO DO AS
MUCH OF THAT.
WE ALSO ALTHOUGH THIS WAS FROM
LAST YEAR -- ONE MAKE NOTE THAT.
WE ARE PROVIDING FOOD TO SENIORS
AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES
SOMETHING WE HAD DONE SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES A WELL WE
INITIATED THAT ACTIVITY LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WE'RE CONTINUING
TO BE SURE THAT HAPPENS.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTES THAT WE
ALSO ARE INVESTING IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT ARE.
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
PROBABLY SPENDING MILLIONS ON
MEASLES OUTBREAK THAT WAS
PREVENTABLE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THINGS LIKE
MEASLES WE NEED TO COMBAT A RISE
IN S. STDS -- VALLEY FEVER OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS AND SO AND THOSE
ACTUALLY THEN KERR GREATER COSTS
TO ALL OF US IF THEY'RE NOT
TAKING CARE OF BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE GET SICK.
THE END OF USING HELP MORE
HEALTH CARE SO WE'RE MAKING
THOSE INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTES THAT.
WAS MENTIONED ABOUT IT PROJECTS
AND BELIEVE ME I'VE BEEN A
CRITIC OF MANY.
NOT SO -- I COULD I WOULD CALL
FAILED BUT CHALLENGED -- IT
PROJECTS BUT I'LL TELL YOU THAT
AS WE'VE EVER SEEN NUMEROUS IT
PROJECTS AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES -- THAT MANY OF THEM
ARE ON TRACK WE'LL SEE HOW THEY
GO BUT YOU KNOW WE ARE PROVIDING
THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT.
AND DOES IT PROJECTS OF A
CONTINUE CHALLENGE OR AGENCIES
SAY THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
INCREASE OUR EFFICIENCY
EFFICIENCY DECREASE THE OVERHEAD
THAT WE ARE SPENDING AS A STATE
TO BE SURE THAT MORE MONEY IS
GOING TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FINALLY ISLA RECOGNIZE IN
ADDITION TO OUR OVERALL RESERVES
TO AND PROFESSIONS PREPARATION
FOR A SESSION WE HAVE ALSO HAVE
A SAFETY NET RESERVE AS WELL TO
BE SURE WE CONTINUE TO BUY.
FOR THEM OUR MOST VULNERABLE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AGAINST AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WHO DEPEND ON
SERVICES LIKE CHILD CARE AND ARE.
IN THAT ACCOUNT SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT.
WE CAN SEE IN THIS BUDGET EVEN
IN JUST THIS ONE SEGMENT ALONE
AND I KNOWTHERE'S WE CAN TALK
ABOUT OTHERS AS WELL.
THAT REALLY ARE ABOUT.
BOTH HELPING PEOPLE IN NEED NOW
BUT IT BUT ALSO PREPARING FOR
THE FUTURE.
MAKING THOSE INVESTMENTS WERE
PREPARED FOR THE FUTURE AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW THIS IS WE TALK
ABOUT THESE OF THE GOOD TIMES
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING IS ARE
TAKING FUNDS AND WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO BE READY BECAUSE
ONE THE WAYS WE'RE GOING TO
PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE IS NOT.
JUST TO HAVE.
A POT OF MONEY TO WORRY BUT THAT
THE DOWNTURN BUT ALSO TO MAKE
THE KIND INVESTMENTS WE NEED NOW.
SO WE CAN DO THINGS SMARTER.
WHICH WE HAVE WE'RE DOING SO
THAT WE ACTUALLY DON'T NEED TO
SPEND THIS MUCH MONEY TO
DOWNTURN STILL PROTECT PEOPLE
PROVIDE PEOPLE THE HELP THEY
NEED AND THOSE ARE SOME THE
THINGS WE'RE DOING IN THIS
BUDGET -- TODAY SO I STAND A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET --
TONIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN THURSTONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
SOMEONE -- TO COMPLEMENT THE THE
BUDGET CHAIR.
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS.
OF THE PRO TEM AN ARM MINORITY
LEADER.
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK.
AND MANY MANY HOURS -- THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVOTED TO THIS BUDGET.
I ALSO WANT -- TO THANK GOD MY
BUDGET SUB THREE CHAIR.
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO.
FOR DOING A GREAT JOB YEAH AND
RUNNING BUDGET SUB THREE AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE MADE A
DIFFERENCE THIS YEAR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT -- WE
RESTORED SOME SERVICES THAT WERE
TAKEN AWAY DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION INCLUDING -- PODIATRY
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CATCH
PEOPLE THAT HAVE UNCONTROLLED
DIABETES EARLIER SO WE CAN STOP --
AMPUTATIONS AUDIOLOGY -- VISION --
WE WE DEFINITELY MADE A
DIFFERENCE AND IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE -- YOUR PARTNER IN THAT
CENTER.
ALSO WHY I THINK IT'S A A GREAT
ATTRIBUTES THE THAT WE SAW A
SIGNIFICANT THAT PAYMENT TO OUR
WALL ABOUT.
OUR WALLET THAT IS ENORMOUS AS
MONEY UNDER CALLING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AS WELL ARTICULATED.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO BE
AGGRESSIVE.
CAN'T AND REMOVING THAT WALLET
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE
THAT WE HAVE THE KIND OF
RESEARCH THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
AND I WANT TO GIVE THE CREDIT
FOR THOSE RESERVES.
PRIMARILY TO THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OFTEN WE HAVE.
TO GET OUR GUIDANCE AND THE
MAN'S FROM NOW.
BEFORE SOMETIMES WE DO.
THE RIGHT THING -- PROP.
TO WE NOW HAVE A RAINY DAY FUND
THAT EXCEEDS TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION.
WE WITNESS AT THE STATE CAN
QUICKLY BE UPSIDE DOWN TO THE
TUNE OF FORTY BILLION DOLLARS.
IF WE HAVE AN ECONOMIC
[inaudible]
DOWNTURN.
AND IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME.
WHEN THE NEXT ECONOMIC DOWNTURN?
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN SO THOSE
RESERVES.
ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND
THE FRAGILITY IF YOU WILL.
OF OUR GENERAL FUND. 1% OF THE
POPULATION MAKES A 50% OF OUR
GENERAL FUND.
MEANING THAT WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
ABOUT DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE.
AND PEOPLE THAT WE LEON.
IN THE NAME OF INCOME INEQUALITY.
WE HAVE AN OPIATE ADDICTION
PROBLEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY THEY WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND WE ALSO HAVE.
AN ADDICTION IN THIS
INSTITUTIONAL COLLARED INDUCTION
THE SPENDING [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
I BELIEVE TO BE.
THE HIGHEST BUDGET.
THAT WE'VE EVER HAD IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WHETHER
BURKE WITH THE SURPLUS OF TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
AND WHILE WE HAVE.
THIS INCREDIBLY LARGE BUT IT
BUDGET WITH THIS INCREDIBLY
LARGE SURPLUS.
WHY WOULD WE BE ENTERTAINING ANY
TAXES AT ALL?
YEAH WE ARE ENTERTAINING.
ANOTHER COUPLE OF BILLION
DOLLARS.
A NEW TAXES IN THIS BUDGET WHICH
I'LL GET TO IN A COUPLE MINUTES
BUT FIRST I WANT TO SAY -- AND I
WANT TO THANK MY AT MY SENATOR
COLLEAGUE FROM MODERATE.
WHO HAS BEEN A CHAMPION OF
DELIVERING CLEAN WATER?
HAS THE RIGHT.
EVERY CALIFORNIAN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THIS FOR YEARS -- I PARTNER
WITH HIM ON MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT HE'S BEEN TRYING
TO DO.
AND I WANT TO CONGRATULATE HIM
AND CONGRATULATE US BUT AFTER HE
PASSES BUDGET.
TODAY AS I ASSUME IT WILL BE
PASSED.
THAT WE WILL GUARANTEE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FOR EVERY PERSON.
THE COMES INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT WE COULD
HAVE VERY EASILY FUNDED THIS.
THERE ARE A BUDGET SURPLUS -- I
KNOW THAT IF YOU LOOK AT A
MOLECULE WATER IT'S H. TOO LOW
NOT SEE TOO WELL.
I STILL FAIL TO SEE THE NEXUS OF
WHAT THE CARBON HAS TO DO-- IN
USING THESE -- CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS TO PAY FOR THIS -- IN.
RESPONSE TO MY FRIEND FROM
FREMONT.
TO HAS VERY WELL ARTICULATED THE
UTILIZATION THESE FUNDS FOR NON.
CLIMATE RELATED ISSUES.
WE HAVE A GOVERNOR THAT SAID
DURING THE STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS THAT.
WE GOT A STOP.
OR WE SHOULD ABBREVIATE THIS.
THIS BULLET TRAIN.
BECAUSE FRANKLY IT'S NOT DOING
WHAT.
IT WAS INTENDED TO DO WE NEED TO
ABBREVIATE IT.
ONLY TO SAY THE NEXT DAY THE WAS
MISCONSTRUED BUT YET WE SEE A
LOT OF CAP AND TRADE FUNDS TO GO
TO THE TRAIN THAT.
FRANKLY OFFERS NO CLIMATE --
BENEFITS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT TAKES ME TO ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION.
YES WE BOAST REGULARLY THAT WE
ARE OF THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
THREE TRILLION DOLLARS IN GROSS
DOMESTIC PRODUCT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW CAN WE AS THE THIRD
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WITH THE BUDGET SURPLUSES THAT
WE HAVE.
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND SOULS.
OUT THERE INCLUDING WOMEN
[inaudible]
INCLUDING CHILDREN [inaudible]
INCLUDING VETERANS.
THAT WE HAVE THROWN MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AT THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
ONLY TO SEE THE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS.
NOT A DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS IN LOS ANGELES ALONE
YEAR AFTER YEAR. 16% INCREASE.
TO SUCH A POINT THAT.
IT'S BECOME A HEALTHCARE CRISIS.
IN LOS ANGELES WHERE WE'RE
WITNESSING TYPHOID FEVER
[inaudible]
SCABIES LICE.
MY FRIENDS THESE ARE HUMAN
BEINGS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IT BREAKS
MY HEART SOMETIMES WHEN.
I'M BEING PICKED UP AT THE
AIRPORT BY SPECIAL SERVICES AND
THE FREEWAY IS JAMMED WE TAKE A
SHORT CUT.
AND WE GO THROUGH THIS TENT CITY
IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I SEE THESE PEOPLE WITH
BONFIRES AND TENSE -- WOMEN --
THAT I CALL OFTEN THE FORGOTTEN
PEOPLE.
WHY AREN'T THEY?
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WITH OUR BUDGET I SEE I THINK
THE BUDGET IS A A REFLECTION OF
OUR VALUES.
AND OUR PRIORITIES.
THERE WAS A BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
THAT WAS.
TRYING TO GIVE.
ALL PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IRRESPECTIVE OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
FULL MEDICAL BENEFITS.
IN FACT IT WAS SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR CHAMPION WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR.
BUT I THINK THE GOVERNOR SOLVE
THE STICKER SHOCK. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND BASICALLY THOSE
BILLS ARE [inaudible]
DO A PROVIDING FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS IS.
IS THE AWAY BUT THE POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS.
IF WE TOOK THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS BEING PROPOSED.
FOR THOSE UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IF
WE AMORTIZED IT TO THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
PEOPLE CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT
YOU'RE CITIES WOULD DO IN YOUR
COUNTIES WOULD DO.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO WRITE A CHECK
FOR EVERY ONE OF THOSE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT'S WHAT WE CAN GIVE THEM
[inaudible]
THE GRAND.
WHERE WE COULD SAY WE ARE GOING
TO HOUSE EVERY HOMELESS PERSON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
THEY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO GET
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THEY
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO GET
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
TALK ABOUT A LEGACY LEGISLATURE.
IF WE COULD DO THAT WE COULD
BASICALLY AND HOMELESSNESS.
AS WE KNOW IT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE
[inaudible]
MY FRIENDS.
I AM ALSO STILL CONCERNED ABOUT
THE THE DELIVERANCE OF SERVICES
TO UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE.
THAT'S GOING TO COST THE
TAXPAYERS NINETY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FISCAL YEAR.
BUT I I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL IS PRAISE
WORTHY.
WE SHOULD BE PHILANTHROPIC AND
WE SHOULD BE ALLOCATING THE
FUNDS.
AND GIVING THE SERVICES TO
UNDERPRIVILEGED AND LOW INCOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN THE
STATE.
BUT IT SHOULD NOT DELUDE OUR
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF THE LESS
FORTUNATE CITIZENS WHO LEGALLY
CALL CALIFORNIA THEIR HOME.
YOU SEE WE HAVE A SYSTEM MEDI
CAL.
THAT IS BASICALLY AN INSURANCE
IN NAME ONLY.
WE'RE BASICALLY SELLING PEOPLE A
CAR.
WITHOUT AN ENGINE.
BECAUSE ONE THING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE FAILS TO DO YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
AND THAT IS A FULL RESTORATION.
OF THE FEES THAT WE PAY
PHYSICIANS TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
CITIZENS [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
THE MEDICAL THREE APPROXIMATE
45% 50% OF THE MEDICARE FEE.
HENCE MOST DOCTORS ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL AREAS THAT I REPRESENT.
REFUSED TO TAKE IT.
SO WE'RE GIVING A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY TO PEOPLE.
THE THINK THEY CAN GET.
HEALTHCARE.
BUT WE'RE REALLY EXACERBATING A
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
RECORDING MORE DOCTORS BUT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ADDING MORE
POPULATION WHICH MEANS THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN TRYING
HARD TO SEE A DOCTOR THAT ARE
LOOK.
LEGAL CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO BE
FURTHER PUSHED OUT.
AND WE'RE STILL GOING TO SEE THE
END AND THE THE THE DEMAND IF
YOU WILL.
OF SERVICES IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM WHICH WE NO COST SO MUCH
MORE MONEY.
WE HAVE 25% OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OF THE ENTIRE NATION.
AND WHAT'S EQUALLY.
APPALLING TO ME.
IT IS A TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX OF THOSE
HOMELESS ARE VETERANS THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT.
PUT IT ALL ON THE LINE FOR US.
WROTE A BLANK CHECK INCLUDING
THEIR LIFE.
SO THAT WE COULD STAND HERE ON
THE FLOOR.
AND HAVE THIS ABILITY TO HAVE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND DEBATE.
OF THIS BUDGET.
IF WE TOOK THAT NINETY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND ADVERTISE IT
TO THE TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX HOMELESS
VETERANS.
WE COULD PUT.
A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS.
AND STILL HAVE FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO SPARE.
BUT WE ALL KNOW MY FRIENDS OF
MONEY DOESN'T GROW ON TREES THAT
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH TO OVER
AROUND YES EVEN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE TO ASK WHY ARE WE
FEELING SO MANY CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS.
RENTS ARE RISING.
UTILITIES ARE GOING UP.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE GAS PRICES
GOING UP FIVE POINT SIX CENTS
THIS YEAR THIS JULY WHY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL AGRICULTURE FEEDS
THE WORLD.
GET EVERY DAY ONE IN FIVE
CHILDREN GO TO BED HUNGRY
[inaudible]
IT'S JUST [inaudible]
IRONIC.
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN STUDY PERFORMED BY THE
BERKATA CENTER AT GEORGE MASON
UNIVERSITY.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
RANKS FORTIETH.
AT A FIFTY IS FIFTY STATES
[inaudible]
EXAMPLE FINE.
BEFORE WE EXPAND SERVICES OF OUR
MEDICAL PROGRAM.
WE NEED TO FIX IT.
SO WHY COLLEAGUES.
HEALTH CARE ACCESSIBILITY IS
MORE THAN JUST BEING INSURED
HEALTH INSURANCE CAN BE RENDERED
UNLESS THE PATIENT CAN'T FIND A
HOSPITAL OR DOCTORS WILLING TO
SEE THEM.
AND AGAIN THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STATE.
DR TED MAZER AND YOUR NOSE AND
THROAT SURGEON ANY PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION EXPLAIN THE
BEST.
THE PROBLEM WITH LOW
REIMBURSEMENT ISN'T THAT DOCTORS
AREN'T MAKING MONEY.
IT'S AT THE DOCTORS AND
HOSPITALS ARE PAYING OUT OF
POCKET TO GIVE CARE. TO MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES THERE'S A LIMIT TO
WHAT YOU CAN DO AND THE PRIVATE
PRACTICE WORLD. TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN.
I WANT TO PLUG THOSE POSITIONS
TO DO THE PHILANTHROPIC CARE
TAKE CARE OF ARE LESS FORTUNATE
CITIZENS.
DID YOU KNOW THAT AN AVERAGE OF
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION CHILDREN
EACH YEAR ENROLLED IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM DO NOT RECEIVE
THE REQUIRED PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
LIKE DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
IMMUNIZATIONS LEAD POISONING
ASSESSMENTS.
AND OPTOMETRY.
THIS WAS FOUND BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
THAT MEANS THAT A CLOSE TO A
QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
NOT.
ACCEPTING THE PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES EVEN THOUGH.
THEY DO HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL.
THE OUR REPORT CITED MANY
REASONS FOR THIS PROBLEM ONE
BEING.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
SERVICES IS A LOT MEDI CAL PLANS
TO SKIRT.
MANDATORY TRAVEL RULES THIS
MEANS THAT MANY FAMILIES ON MEDI
CAL TYPICALLY LOW INCOME.
WOULD HAVE TO TRAVEL HUNDREDS OF
MILES OR SEVERAL HOURS TO GET TO
A DOCTOR.
AND THESE FAMILIES JUST DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY OR CAPACITY TO
DO THAT THAT CERTAINLY IS TRUE
IN MY DISTRICT.
WHERE IT'S TWO HOURS FROM PALM
DESERT TO BLIGHT?
IN THE EXPANSIVE COUNTY THAT I
REPRESENT.
THAT'S AGAIN CHILDREN ARE
GETTING THE ACCESS THEY NEED IS
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM.
ANOTHER PROBLEM THAT THE AUDIT
FOUND WAS A MEDI CAL WAS FILLING
TO ENSURE PLANS THAT MEET THE
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
DIVERSE POPULATION AS WELL AS
LOW PROVIDER REIMBURSE RIVERS
FROM RATES CONTINUE.
CALIFORNIA'S LAWMAKERS AND MADE
IT A PRIORITY TO DRIVE DOWN THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNINSURED BUT AMAZINGLY WE HAVE
ONE OF THE LOWEST INSURED RATES
IN THE NATION AT ABOUT 7% NOW.
AND WE HAVE THIRTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS --
COVERED.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
UNDERMINE OUR GOAL OF EXPANDING
ACCESS TO CARE BY FAILING TO
REIMBURSE DOCTORS A LIVABLE
RATES.
SOME OF MY FRIENDS.
I TALK ABOUT WHY WE ARE RAISING
TAXES A FEW BILLION DOLLARS SO
WE HAVE THESE BUDGET SURPLUSES.
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE A
DEDUCTION COMES OFF OF ALL OF
OUR PAYCHECKS.
WE'RE GONNA DRAWDOWN RESERVES
AND THEN ALL OF OUR CITIZENS
THAT WORK AND HAVE.
PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS WILL SEE
ANOTHER TEMP OR TWO TENTHS OF A
PERCENT.
TAKEN OUT OF THEIR PAYCHECKS.
WE HAVE A CELL PHONE TAX SO WE
COULD VERY EASILY A FUNDED
THROUGH OUR BUDGET SURPLUSES A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS VITALLY IMPORTANT
SOMETHING WE LEARNED DURING THE
THE FIRES OF OF LAST YEAR.
SOMETHING THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
HAS ALREADY DONE.
WE INVESTED IN OUR COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM SO THAT WE HAVE A REVERSE
NINE ONE ONE WE CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
JURISDICTION FROM ANY PART OF
THE STATE OR COUNTRY.
THAT COMES INTO OUR
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE NEEDS
TO DO THIS.
BUT WE DON'T NEED TO RAISE THE
TAX ON ALL THE CELL PHONES THE
NUMBERS.
THAT AGAIN HAS A REGRESSIVE
IMPACT.
ON THE POOREST OF CALIFORNIANS.
AND THAT WE TALK ABOUT WE'RE
GONNA BE FIGHTING AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE TO CITIZENS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR TO THE MIDDLE CLASS.
BUT WHAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
[inaudible]
THE LOWER [inaudible]
INCOME FOLKS.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE INSURANCE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
CAN NOW PAY THE STATE MANDATE OF
SIX HUNDRED NINETY FIVE DOLLARS.
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE NOT TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD INSURANCE SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE.
MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE TO MAKE UP
WHAT.
UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A SUBSIDY ON
BEHALF OF THE POOR POOREST
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO DELIVER
HEALTHCARE.
WHICH I THINK IS COMPLETELY
WRONG.
AND THEN PROMISES THAT ARE MADE
SHOULD BE PROMISES THAT ARE
CAPPED [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
PROP FIFTY SIX TOBACCO FUNDS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE USED [inaudible]
TO HELP.
THE MEDICAL SYSTEM RAISING MEDI
CAL FEES.
BUT WE HAVE SUSPENSIONS AT THIS
GOVERNOR IS GOING TO USE TO
RETAKE TO RATE THE FUND. FOR
GENERAL FUND BUDGETARY PURPOSES.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE CITIZENS VOTED FOR
IMPROPER [inaudible] FIFTY SIX
SO MY FRIENDS [inaudible]
THE BUDGET.
DOES A LOT OF GOOD FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE VERY BLESSED TO HAVE THE
INCOME STREAM SO WE HAVE COMING
IN AND THAT'S BECAUSE WERE THE
HIGHEST TAX TO THE SINS IN THE
COUNTRY WE HAD PROP THIRTY TAXES%
OPPOSED TO BE TEMPORARY THAT
BECAME PERMANENT.
AGAIN. TO ALL THE CITIZENS THAT
ARE LISTENING TO THIS.
THERE'S NO SUCH THINGS AS A
TEMPORARY TAX IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO BE WHERE.
BUT WE NEED TO KEEP OUR PROMISES
TO THE TO THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE.
WE NEED TO USE OUR MONEY WISELY.
WE DON'T NEED TO BE ADDING TAXES
WHEN IN FACT WE HAVE BUDGET
SURPLUSES.
AND WE CAN'T KEEP IMPACTING.
THE POOREST OF CALIFORNIANS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN WITH RESERVE
PRESS OF TAXES.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS I URGE
NO VOTE ON THIS BUDGET BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
[inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
WELL COLLEAGUES I HOPE THAT I
CAN NOW ELEVATE YOUR MOODS
BECAUSE I STANDING GREAT SUPPORT
OF THIS BUDGET.
AND I WANT TO SAY.
THE GOVERNOR.
ADMINISTRATION ALL OF THE STAFF.
OUR BUDGET STAFF.
OUR BUDGET CHAIR.
EVERYONE WHO WORKED ON THIS
BUDGET AND OF COURSE OUR PRO.
TEN FOR LANDING SOMETHING WHICH
I THINK.
IS AN INCREDIBLE.
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIANS REGULAR
CALIFORNIANS -- IT'S A BUDGET
[inaudible]
THAT.
ALMOST EVERY CALIFORNIAN IS
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM.
AND I COULD EXPLAIN WHY BUT
BEFORE I DO.
HOLD UP THIS PROP [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
WE COULD.
SEE THIS GLASS AS HALF EMPTY AND
WE'VE HEARD MANY COMMENTS TODAY.
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY DESCRIBE.
WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO VOTE ON THIS
HALF EMPTY? FOR WE COULD SEE
THIS GLASS IS HALF FULL. TO SAY
IT'S MORE THAN HALF FULL.
AND I'M GONNA SAY I HIM SO HAPPY
AS A SIX TIME BUDGET CONFEREES.
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT A BUDGET
THAT I CAN GO HOME AND TELL MY
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO DESCRIBE IT'S
BRING IN BENEFITS TO THEM.
INSTEAD OF THE MANY YEARS WHERE
I HAD TO GO HOME AND TELL.
THOSE FAMILIES THAT DEPENDED ON
IN HOME HEALTH SERVICES SORRY
IT'S BEEN CUT IN HALF.
OR MY PTA ABOUT HOW MANY FEWER
TEACHERS WERE GOING TO BE IN
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEXT YEAR.
OR MY FAMILY'S THAT COULD BARELY
AFFORD CHILDCARE HOW BE SICKLY
CHILD CARE CENTERS WE'RE GOING
TO BE CLOSE OR ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THAT WE HAD TO DO.
TO CUT.
THE BUDGET IN THOSE TERRIBLE
RECESSION YEARS. FOR ME JUST
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE REASONS WHY
I'M SO WHEN.
YOU SEE ASKED TO CLEAN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET. FOR
EXAMPLE AT LEAST TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
TEN THOUSAND MORE WILL BE ABLE
TO ATTEND ARE YOU SEE AND CSU
SYSTEM.
AND ALL OF OUR STUDENTS TO
ATTEND HIGHER READ ARGUED IN A
BENEFIT FINANCIALLY WITH OUR
EXPANSION OF CAL GRANTS
[inaudible] FOR FAMILIES. FOR
MANY OF THEM EVEN THOSE WHO MAKE
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND A
YEAR.
THE HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS ARE
VERY HARD TO AFFORD.
SO FOR THOSE FAMILIES WE ARE
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE SO THEY CAN
MEET.
BETTER HEALTH CARE INSURANCE
COSTS [inaudible]
THE END.
SO THAT OUR NEW APPEARANCE CAN
SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME.
WITH THEIR BABIES.
WHETHER ADOPTED OR BOARD TO THEM.
WE'VE INCREASED PAID FAMILY
LEAVE TIME.
AND THEN OF COURSE WHEN THEY'RE
READY TO GO BACK TO WORK.
AND A FACE CHILD CARE COSTS THAT
ARE.
MORE EXPENSIVE THE COLLEGE.
WE HAVE EXPANDED THE
AVAILABILITY AND THE
AFFORDABILITY OF CHILD CARE.
AND WE'VE ENSURED FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AND EXPANDED THE
PRE K. FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS AND
LET ME TELL YOU AS A WORKING
MOTHER WHEN KINDERGARTEN WAS A
HALF DAY.
I MEAN YOU KNOW THE CHILD CARE
COST BEFORE KINDERGARTEN WERE
HIGH ENOUGH BUT THEN WHEN I HAD
TO FIGURE OUT WHO IS GOING TO
GET MY KID FROM KINDERGARTEN. TO
WHEREVER SHE WAS GOING TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF BEFORE I COULD GET
HOME FROM WORK AND THEN COVER
THAT COST.
WAS EXORBITANT.
NOW WE'VE.
FAMILIES ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
TO FACE THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ARE GETTING
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IN TAX
RELIEF WITH THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THAT WE EXPECT TO PASS NEXT
WEEK.
AND SMALL BUSINESSES WHILE.
WE LOOK AT THE INCREDIBLE WEALTH
OF CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATIONS AND
WE NOW HAVE A CITY WITH MORE
BILLIONAIRES PER CAPITA THAN ANY
OTHER CITY.
IT IS STILL SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
ECONOMY THEY ARE THE MAIN
PROVIDER OF JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE GIVING THEM.
TAX RELIEF.
AND OUR MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS.
AND STILL THERE ARE MANY
CALIFORNIANS TO RELY ON MINIMUM
WAGE AND THEY FIND IT MORE AND
MORE DIFFICULT TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
THEY'RE GONNA GET A BENEFIT FROM
THE INCREASE IN OUR EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
AND OF COURSE AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
ARE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE REELING
FROM THE HEART BREAKING INCREASE
IN HOMELESSNESS.
AND THOSE CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES HOMELESS WERE
ON THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS.
ARE GOING TO GET AN INCREDIBLE
BENEFIT WITH THIS BUDGET WHERE
WE HAVE INCREASED THE FUNDING.
TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE.
MORE SHELTER MORE HOMELESS
SERVICES.
MORE PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
FACING THE BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS
WE HAVE.
FUNDS FOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE IN
EMERGENCY RENTAL INSISTENCE SO
IF THEY FACE THAT FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLAR UNEXPECTED INCREASE IN
EXPENSES OR THAT FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLAR.
EXPENSE THAT THEY DIDN'T EXPECT
THAT ALL OF THE SUDDEN PUTS HIM
IN A POSITION WHERE MAYBE THEY
COULDN'T PAY RENT WHICH COULD
THEN PUT HIM IN A POSITION OF
BEING AFFECTED WHICH THEN BAD
STORE HOMELESS RULES WE'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE.
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
WHAT IS BETTER THAN THAT?
AND WITH ALL OF THIS.
WE HAVE PUT AWAY FOR THAT
EXPECTED RAINY DAY.
AND NOT NLY WITH PUTTING
INVESTING AT LEAST TWENTY
BILLION IN THAT RAINY DAY FUND
BUT ALSO TOPPING UP.
OUR ONE MINUTE BLOW ITS NAME
EXCUSE ME OUR OF A SAFETY NET
RESERVE AND A COUPLE OF THE
OTHER RESERVES THAT WE'VE
CREATED.
SO.
THIS IS WHY I STAND BEFORE YOU
EN INSTITUCIONES STICKLEY
RECOMMEND YOUR BY VOTE THE GLASS
IS MORE THAN HALF FULL.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT [inaudible]
I JOIN.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS CONFERENCE
REPORT [inaudible]
AND ADOPT THE PASSION HUMANITY
ENTHUSIASM OF MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE.
ON BEHALF OF THIS CONFERENCE
REPORT.
I HAVE SPENT.
MANY YEARS IN AT LEAST A LACKS
DECADE.
FOCUSING.
ON WHAT DEEPLY CONCERNS ME ABOUT
THE STRUCTURE.
OF OUR CALIFORNIA FINANCES.
AND THAT IS OUR EXTRAORDINARY
VOLATILITY WHICH HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED BY MANY OF THE
SPEECHES HERE TODAY ON THIS
FLOOR.
AND THOSE THAT VOLATILITY IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS DETERMINED
BASED UPON THE COUNTLESS POINT
OF VIEW.
BUT A VERY HUMAN POINT OF VIEW
ABOUT FURLOUGHS AND PROGRAM
CUTBACKS IT IMPACTS FOSTER KIDS
AND ALL THE VARIOUS THINGS THAT
WE CARE ABOUT.
AND SO I THINK ABOUT THE LONG
TERM.
ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE.
AND WHY RISE TODAY IS TO SAY
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE NEW
REVENUES AND YES I KNOW WE CAN-IT TAKE HERE AND THERE BUT YOU
LOOK AT THE BIG FRAME. 82%
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN 82% OF THIS
SURPLUS MONEY IN THIS BUDGET BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION BY THIS
LEGISLATURE EITHER GOES TO A
RESERVE ACCOUNT OF WHICH THERE
ARE A NUMBER AS WAS MENTIONED.
PAID OUT ALL THAT.
AND PRE PAY PENSIONS 82%.
NOW THAT DOES CERTAINLY HELPS US
IN THE NEAR TERM IN THE EVENT
THERE SOME LEVEL OF DOWNTURN.
BUT I THINK IT EVIDENCE IS A
LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE'RE FOCUSED.
OF WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IN BOTH
HOUSES AND THE GOVERNOR.
ARE FOCUSED IN TERMS OF FOLK --
OF DEALING WITH THIS LARGER
PROBLEM AND I SUSPECT IN YEARS
TO COME AS WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL ISSUE.
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
VOLATILITY THAT WE CAN PLAN SO
THAT WE AVOID THE FURLOUGHS WE
AVOID THE CUT BACKS WE AVOID
FUTURE LEGISLATORS HAVING TO
DEAL WITH WITH SO MANY OF HAD TO
DEAL WITH ON THIS FLOOR.
DEALING WITH TERRIBLE CUTBACKS
AND TERRIBLE CHALLENGE IN THIS
BUDGET I APPLAUD THOSE WHO
WORKED ON IT I APPLAUD THE
EFFORT I APPLAUD THE PRODUCT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
SENATOR JACKSON.
YES SIR -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ALSO INSURE THE SONG CASE SERASA
RAW.
A VERY MUCH IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
SONG IT'S THE STORY OF A MOTHER
AND A DAUGHTER IS THE DAUGHTER
ASKS THE ADVICE OF HER MOTHER
WHAT.
WILL MY FUTURE BE.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WOULD LIKE TO
AND HER MOTHER IN PERHAPS HER
GRANDMOTHER.
WHAT THAT FUTURE WILL BE WITH
THE HELP OF THIS BUDGET?
WE HAVE NOW AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BY SEVERAL OTHERS A
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION SOMETIMES
CALLED CHILD CARE.
HOW CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THOSE
FIRST THREE YEARS ARE OF A
CHILD'S LIFE AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GROW AND
DEVELOP THEIR BRAIN?
AND SO BY THIS BUDGET WE ARE.
ADDING ADDITIONAL ESOURCES OF
FOR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND
THE CARE GIVERS WHO ARE THEIR
EARLIEST EDUCATORS WERE ADDING
AN ADDITIONAL TWO WEEKS SO THAT
PARENTS CAN SPEND THE TIME TO
BOND WITH THEIR NEWBORNS.
HOPEFULLY AS YEARS GO ON WE WILL
ADD MORE TIME SO THE PARENTS AND
THEIR NEWBORNS CAN DEVELOP THOSE
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS THAT
MOST OF THE REST OF THE
DEVELOPED WORLD HAS LONG
ACKNOWLEDGED AS IMPORTANT.
WE ALSO HAVE UP FISCAL
COMPONENTS DEEPLY ROOTED IN THIS
BUDGET INCLUDING.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND CAL
WORKS ALIGNMENT IN ADDITION WE
HAVE DONE WITH THIS BUDGET --
ADDITIONAL MONIES FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AS THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY -- SADLY IS
TRYING TO CHALLENGE THE RIGHTS
OF THE WOMEN HAVE TO THE
REPRODUCTIVE DECISION MAKING AND
REPRODUCTIVE CAL HEALTH CARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE ADDING
THOSE IMPORTANT RESOURCES SO
THAT WOMEN.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
CARE FOR THEMSELVES AND THE
DECISION MAKING IN THE
INDEPENDENCE THAT COMES WITH
THAT DECISION MAKING.
SO FOR OVER A DECADE PERHAPS TWO
DECADES NOW THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS FOUGHT FOR
GENDER ANY ECONOMIC EQUITY.
THAT WOMEN AND FAMILIES TO SERVE
AND THIS BUDGET MOVES US FORWARD
IN THAT EFFORT HOPEFULLY MUCH
MORE TO COME IN THE FUTURE.
AND AS MY JEWISH MOTHER USED TO
SAY THE GLASS MAY BE HALF EMPTY.
BUT IT IS HALF FULL AND WHEN YOU
CAN GET THAT OUT OF A JEWISH
MOTHER YOU'RE REALLY MAKING
PROGRESS THIS IS A GOOD BUDGET.
THIS IS AN EX SELECT IT IS MY
THIRTEENTH BUDGET IT IS THE MOST.
RESPONSIBLE YET BOLD BUDGET IN
ADDRESSING THE FUTURE THIS STATE
BUT DEALING WITH THE REALITIES
THAT COME FROM THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD -- I AM THE
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO STAND HERE
AND SUPPORTED AND WILL BE VERY
PROUD TO CASH MY AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF OF THIS BUDGET FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR AHEAD.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
ATKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AND IN A KNOWLEDGE MEN OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY LET ME
JUST SAY.
FROM WHERE I GREW UP WE JUST
HAVE GRATITUDE FOR THE GLASS --
YOU KNOW HIGH -- LET THAT SINK
IN -- YOU KNOW I I ACTUALLY
REALLY BELIEVE WE HAVE BEFORE US
THE BEST BUDGET IN MORE THAN TWO
DECADES IF NOT EVER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT A LUXURY WE
HAVE. TO GET TO STAND HERE AND
ARGUE OVER WHERE WE SHOULD PUT
OUR SAVINGS.
HOW WE SHOULD SPEND SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY WE HAVE? TO
SUPPORT STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS.
ARE WHO FOR DECADES HAVE SEEN
SOME OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED -- WHAT A LUXURY WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO STAND HERE
AND ARGUE OVER CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT WERE
TRYING?
TO ENHANCE OUR BRING BACK.
A TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET THAT.
THAT SUPPORT SO MANY THINGS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
MENTIONED I DON'T NEED TO TO
REPEAT -- ALL OF THOSE THINGS --
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE ONE I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT WATER -- YOU KNOW
THIS BODIES VERY MINDFUL ABOUT
FEE INCREASES IN TAX INCREASES
IT'S WHY WE APPROACH THE WATER
ISSUE.
I IN THE WAY THAT WE DID.
AND YOU DON'T LET ME JUST SAY
WHAT A LUXURY TO HAVE BOTTLED
WATER.
WHEN I GREW UP IN SOUTHWEST
VIRGINIA AND CARRIED WATER FROM
A SPRING WE DIDN'T HAVE BOTTLED
WATER TO EVEN BRING IN?
SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO GET
WATER FROM A A RAIN BARREL AND
FROM A SPRING.
AND TO COOK ON A WOOD STOVE AND
MAKE SURE YOU HEAT THE WATER FOR
WHATEVER PURPOSE FOR FOOD. TO
TAKE A BATH AND A TEN TUB -- YOU
KNOW I KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE.
SO I'VE BEEN IN BOTH WORLDS I'VE
BEEN IN THE WORLD WITHOUT IT.
AND I LIVE IN THE WORLD WITH IT.
AND THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SHOULD LIVE THAT
WAY TODAY.
NOT ONE AND SO THAT WE HAVE
FOUND A WAY TO DO THIS -- IT WAS
OUR INTENT TO USE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS -- BUT YOU KNOW WHAT.
ARE WE MADE THE BEST OF A
NEGOTIATION ACROSS -- THREE
PARTIES AND WE DID WHAT WE HAD
TO DO -- SOMEWHAT RELUCTANTLY IN
TERMS OF HOW IN ORDER TO GET IT
DONE AND I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM WHO
STRETCHED. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS AT STAKE IN MAKING THAT
DECISION THAT WAS IMPORTANT AND
I THANK YOU FOR THAT -- YOU KNOW
OUR FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY OH MY
GOSH HOW DO HOW MUCH OF A LUXURY
IS IT FOR US. TO BE ABLE TO PUT
A BUDGET FORWARD THAT WE HAVE
WORKED.
YEARS TO GET TO THE POINT -- MY
BUDGET CHAIRED TODAY'S STARTED
NINE YEARS AGO AND SHE'S BEEN ON
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE EVER SENSE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY TO THE YEAH.
SENATE SHE'S CHAIR BUDGET THE
CONFEREES -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY HAS BEEN IN A COM FREE
FOR MANY I THINK SHE SAID.
FIVE WE HAVE THE BEST EXPERIENCE
HERE TODAY THAT'S HAD TO
NEGOTIATE AND TOUGH BUDGETS.
AND BETTER BUDGETS.
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY WAS
SOMETHING WE ASPIRE TO AND IT
CAME A BELT.
BECAUSE WE PUT FORWARD AN IDEA
OF A RAINY DAY FUND FROM THE
ASSEMBLY I WAS HERE.
THE GOVERNOR EMBRACED IT WANTED
TO DO IT WE GAVE STRUCTURE TO IT.
AND THEN WE TOOK IT TO THE
CITIZENS AND THEY DID WHAT WE
KNEW THEY WOULD WHICH WAS TO SAY
YES WE WANT THAT.
SO WE HAVE.
A RAINY DAY FUND WE HAVE A
REGULAR RESERVE WE HAVE A SAFETY
NET RESERVE WE HAD TO WE HAVE AN
EDUCATION RESERVE.
AND WE'RE PAYING DOWN DEBT.
AND WE'RE PAYING DOWN PENSION
LIABILITY.
THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT MY
COLLEAGUE TO THE RIGHT OF ME
HERE THE MAJORITY LEADER GAVE
THE PERCENTAGE.
WHAT A LUXURY THAT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO PROMOTE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY?
IN OUR BUDGET.
BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
FEEL.
THE BENEFIT OF THE SURPLUS.
AND SO WHAT WE TRY TO DO TO
BALANCE THAT.
WAS TO PUT RESOURCES INTO
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT THEY ARE.
LOWER INCOME MIDDLE CLASS LIFE.
SO THAT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
IN THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD WHERE WE HAVE MOST OF
THE VENTURE CAPITALIST.
IS IT PERFECT NO IT ISN'T WE ARE
NOT GOING TO GET TO PERFECT
PEOPLE.
IF YOU THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE PERFECT IT IS NOT IN THIS
LIFETIME.
BUT I TELL YA WE HAVE.
ASPIRATIONS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE NORTH SOUTHEAST
WEST CENTRAL.
THAT THEY HAVE SOMETHING THAT
CAN MAKE THEM FEEL HOPEFUL.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THE
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE CHALLENGES.
WE'VE GOTTEN TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY BUT MONDAY.
WE GOT TRAILER BILL SAY GIVE YOU
ALL KINDS OF DETAILS ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT HAPPEN
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET CLOSER.
TO MAKING IT HAPPEN FOR OUR
NEIGHBORS OUR CONSTITUENTS WE
HAVE A HOUSING PROBLEM.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THIS KIND OF
CRISIS A DECADE AGO BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T IN THE BOILING WATER YET.
ALONG WITH THE LOBSTER WE
WEREN'T THERE.
BUT WERE THERE NOW.
AND WE'VE GOT REAL STUFF WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO SOLVE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WERE ACTUALLY DOING
SOME GOOD WE ARE NOT SOLVING ALL
THESE PROBLEMS OVERNIGHT BUT IF
WE ARE NOT WORKING TOWARDS.
BETTER SOLUTIONS SHAME ON US AND
SO EACH OF US REALLY HAS THE
ABILITY AND THE LUXURY TO
QUIBBLE.
WITH A PIECE OF IT OR A PIECE OF
THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO GO
HOME TODAY TO MY COMMUNITY WELL
I'M I'M AWAKE SEE WHAT GETS PUT
IN PRINT.
AND THEN I'M GONNA GO HOME AT
SOME POINT. TO MY COMMUNITY
FEELING LIGHT. FIVE FEELING LIKE
WE HOPEFULLY HAVE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
OUR JOB IS LEGISLATORS ON OUR
MOST IMPORTANT TASK.
APPROVING A BUDGET FOR OUR STATE
THAT IS OUR MOST IMPORTANT TASK.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO COME BACK ON
MONDAY.
MADAM BUDGETARY KNOW YOUR WILL
BE HERE ALL WEEKEND BUT WE HAVE
TO COME BACK ON MONDAY.
AND FINISH THE JOB.
AND THAT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
NEXT WEEK.
WE CAN'T LET OUR CHALLENGES KEEP
US FROM DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TODAY.
AND ON MONDAY.
OUR CONSTITUENTS EXPECT US TO
BALANCE THESE ISSUES.
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY PUT MONEY
AWAY PROVIDED SOME SERVICES THAT
THEY HAVEN'T HAD FOR A DECADE
MAKING SURE THEIR KIDS CAN GO TO
COLLEGE.
AND YEAH WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO HOUSE PEOPLE.
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION MORE
DOLLARS FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE IS A
START.
AND THEN WE'VE GOT A WHOLE
HOUSING PACKAGE WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT BECAUSE THAT'S ABOUT
PRODUCTION.
WE KEEP PUTTING MONEY THERE BUT
IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH THE
PRODUCTION AND WE KNOW WHAT WE
KNOW WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH A
CHALLENGE SO I WOULD JUST SAY.
I FEEL PRETTY GOOD ABOUT THE
GLASS AND THE WATER THAT'S IN IT
RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL PRETTY GOOD AND I FEEL
PRETTY PROUD OF MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE IN THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE ASKED.
AND THE NATURAL TENSION THAT WE
PLACE UPON OURSELVES FROM THE
POSITION OF BEING IN THE SENATE
THE ASSEMBLY THE GOVERNOR THAT
TENSION FROM THE DEMOCRATS THE
REPUBLICANS THAT TENSION.
THAT WE PUT ON EACH OTHER IS
NECESSARY AND SO.
I FEEL HAPPY THAT WE GET TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY.
BECAUSE WE ARE THE FORTUNATE
ONES TO GET TO HAVE IT AND WE'RE
THE ONES WHO GET TO GO HOME.
AND FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WE ARE DOING?
IN ALL OF THOSE LINE ITEMS.
THAT HELPS EACH INDIVIDUAL
PERSON THAT WE'RE GONNA RUN INTO
SO I IMPLORE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT.
I IMPLORE YOU TO THINK OVER THE
WEEKEND ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE
STILL HAVE TO DO I IMPLORE YOU
TO THINK.
ABOUT -- THE BILL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE -- TO SUPPORT AND
TAKE UP ON MONDAY THAT ACTUALLY
HELPS US MAKE THIS A REALITY AND
WHAT IT DOES FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND I URGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE STILL HAVE YET TO DO AND
AND TO FEEL SOME SENSE OF OF
RESPONSIBILITY THAT YOU'VE DONE
YOUR JOB TODAY.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WITH MY INCREDIBLE THANKS
TO ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU MAN APPROACHED HIM
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
PRESIDENT.
AND LET ME START BY THANKING ALL
OF YOU WHO HAVE THANKED US WHO --
SERVE YOU -- ON THROUGH THIS
BUDGET PROCESS I WANT TO THANK
MY PRO TIM FOR IT GIVING ME THE
TRUE HONOR.
OF SERVING AS YOUR BUDGET CHAIR
OF THE VICE CHAIR -- OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ALWAYS SAYS IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK WE AS A
BODY DO.
AND I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
AND WITH THAT.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE MANY OF US PERHAPS
DISAGREE.
WE CAN ALL AGREE.
THAT WHEN CALIFORNIANS ARE AT
RISK [inaudible]
IN TROUBLE.
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES THEIR
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES.
WHEN THEIR BACKS AGAINST THE
WALL THEY CALL US?
AND THEY LOOK TO US.
AND THIS BUDGET INCLUDES
[inaudible]
A RESPONSIBLE WITH BOND SERVANT.
REACTION IN SUPPORT. TO JUST
THOSE CALIFORNIANS.
AND NONE OF US SHOULD FORGET
THAT.
THE WORK OF GOVERNMENT SERVICE.
THAT'S THE WORK GOVERNMENT
PRODUCES.
IT'S EITHER THROUGH TECHNOLOGY
OR MAN OR WOMAN POWER.
AND SO IT'S OUR JOB TO GUARANTEE
THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS CAN
RELY ON THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT
AND STATE DEPARTMENTS.
THEY HAVE TRAINED PERSONNEL TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS.
SOMEONE MENTIONED DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES.
IT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE OF US
TO CHOKE OF THAT DEPARTMENT TO
PREVENT THEM FROM PROVIDING THE
CRITICAL SERVICE.
THE EVERY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
REQUIRES.
SO IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. TO ENGAGE
IN OVERSIGHT AND TO PARTNER WITH
THAT DEPARTMENT AS LONG AS WELL
AS ALL THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S.
TO NAVIGATE THROUGH.
THE CHALLENGES THEY MAY BE
EXPERIENCING. TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE THEY CAN PROVIDE EXCELLENT
QUALITY SERVICE THE EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
THAT'S OUR JOB TO DO.
I WELL WE CAN'T SEE THE FUTURE.
OUR JOB IS TO PLAN FOR IT TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITIES BASED ON
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE TODAY
AND OUR EXPERIENCE FROM THE PAST.
PAYING DOWN DEBT.
HELPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THEIR PENSION LIABILITY.
INVESTING IN OUR FUTURE QUITE
LITERALLY OUR CHILDREN.
AND WE'RE DOING THAT IN THIS
BUDGET.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW COLLEGE YOU'VE
HEARD ME SAY BEFORE CHILDREN
DON'T GET DO OVERS.
THEY DON'T GET TO STILL BE THREE
YEARS OLD WAITING FOR US TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THEM A
SEAT IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS.
THEY DON'T GET TO STAY IN THE
FIFTH GRADE WHILE WE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE ROOM FOR THEM.
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
THEY DON'T GET TO STAY IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHILE WE FIGURE OUT.
HOW?
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT SLOTS FOR THEM IN
THEIR PUBLICLY FUNDED COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
YOU KNOW WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
COLLEAGUES I MUST SAY THAT IT'S
DISINGENUOUS. TO ASK FOR A FAVOR
IN THE BUDGET THAT YOU DON'T
SUPPORT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO DRILLING DOWN
TO THE SPECIFICS NEXT WEEK AS WE
DISCUSS REGULAR BILLS WHICH OF
THE SPENDING PLAN FOR THIS.
BUDGET. FOR THINGS LIKE NINE ONE
ONE SERVICES TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO LIVE IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
TAX BREAKS TO SMALL BUSINESSES
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO EMPLOY MORE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THEN THE
BIG BUSINESSES ARE COLLEAGUES
CLAIM ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA IN
DROVES.
FINALLY COLLEAGUES THERE IS NO
PORK IN THIS BUDGET.
IT CONTAINS INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICES.
A GOOD RESPONSIBLE USE OF ONE
TIME DOLLARS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND WITH REGARD TO TIMELINESS
WELL.
I WAS HAPPY AS BUDGET CHAIR TO
RECEIVE LETTER AS LATE AS FRIDAY.
FROM A COLLEAGUE WHO NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN HIS DISTRICT A
DISTRICT COULD BE RAVAGED BY
NATURAL DISASTER.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
SUPPORT FOR THAT COMMUNITY IS
CONTAINED IN THIS BUDGET.
SO YOU'RE WELCOME.
AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
WELCOME FROM THOSE OF US WHO
WILL CAST A VOTE TODAY THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE NEEDS TODAY
[inaudible]
AND TOMORROW.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT CASES THE RAFI
RON THE FACT THAT THAT WAS THE
MESSAGE FROM A MOTHER.
TO A DAUGHTER WELL.
OUT HERE WITH YOU ALL MY
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT A HOME
APPOINTMENT BY LANGSTON HUGHES
ENTITLED MOTHER TO SON.
AND I THE POLL ON THIS MOTHER
SAYS LIFE FOR ME AIN'T BEEN NO
CRYSTAL STAIR.
THERE BEEN PATCHES IN THE
STAIRCASE THERE BEEN PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE BLANDLY INSIDE HAD
TO TURN IT'S BEEN A ROUGH SPOT.
BUT IN SHORT SHE CHALLENGES THAT
SON TO JUST KEEP CLIMBING
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO CALL HIM TO
CLIMB TO A BETTER LIFE THAN SHE
EXPERIENCED.
THIS COLLEAGUES WITH INVESTMENTS
IN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
MUSEUMS AND PARKS AND GREEN
SPACES.
REFLECTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
BETTER LIFE A BETTER LIFE FOR
THE CHILDREN COMING BEHIND US
AND A BETTER LIFE AND A BETTER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF US TO GROW
OLD IN.
IT'S BEEN MY PLEASURE TO SERVE
ALL WITH ALL OF YOU IN BUILDING
A BUDGET THAT WE CAN ALL BE
PROUD OF AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
OF A. B..
SEVENTY FOUR THE USER MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
HI.
BATES.
NO BELL.
BY PORGES [inaudible]
NO.
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HILL BY WITH SO.
BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
IRAQ.
BY WINNER HI WILK [inaudible]
NO.
I TWENTY ONE THOSE ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. TWENTY NINE
WOULD AYE SAM SORRY EYES.
TWENTY NINE OF THOSE ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES I'M NOT USED TO
SEEING SO MANY EYES IN THE DIM
SIDE I GUESS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO SENATE THIRD READING AND
LIFT THE CALL ON ITEM FORTY
SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE. FIVE THIRTY NINE
DOES ZERO THE RESOLUTION PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR JUNE TENTH THROUGH THE
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS ALSO WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL ADOPT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THAT CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY
JUNE FOURTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ADOPTED PRINTED AND RETURNED
TO COMMITTEE.
WE'RE STILL ON SENATOR BOARD
RESURGENCE.
YES MA'AM PRESIDENT MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I WOULD ASK THAT --
WE PLEASE REMOVE A. B. SEVEN
FIFTY NINE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IN PLACE IT ON THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR DESK
WILL NOTE.
ANYTHING ELSE ANYONE WANTS MOVE
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
ONE OF SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR NINE SIX AND FILE ITEM ONE
OH NINE ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU THE
DESK WILL NOTE ANYTHING ELSE
ANYONE WANTS TO REMOVE.
VERY GOOD MEMBERS WE ARE STILL
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THIS WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR A JOURNEY IN MEMORIES
[inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS TODAY I STAND TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF AN INCREDIBLE MAN.
A DEAR FRIEND A MENTOR WHO AYE
MY FAMILY CALLED UNCLE.
JACK THE WHITE.
HE WAS A PUBLIC SERVANT A LEADER
AND A GREAT FAMILY MAN.
HE DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO PUBLIC
SERVICE HE SERVED HIS COMMUNITY
AND HIS COUNTRY HONORABLY.
JACK WAS THE FIRST ELECTED MAYOR
OF MY HOME TOWN BALDWIN PARK.
HE ALSO SERVED AS A MEMBER OF
THE BALLPARK UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
HE WAS A HUGE ADVOCATE FOR
EDUCATION AND BECAME A CHAMPION
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OFTEN SAID.
JACK WHITE MODEL THE VALUES WE
HOPE TO INSTILL IN EVERY STUDENT
UPON PARK UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
HE MADE SUCH A POSITIVE IMPACT.
BUT THE HIGH SCHOOL STADIUM WAS
NAMED AFTER HIM.
JACK WHITE WAS ALSO A VETERAN.
HE SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN THE
KOREAN WAR AND WAS A PARATROOPER
FOR THE ARMY'S EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE DIVISION FROM. NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE TO NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
HIS SERVICE DIDN'T STOP THERE.
HE WORKED FOR LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AS THE POLICE
COMMANDER.
HE TOOK MANY YOUNG MEN UNDER HIS
WING.
HE LATER LEFT THE DEPARTMENT TO
SERVE AS CHIEF OF THE BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO NINETEEN
NINETY TWO HE ALWAYS MENTORED
PEOPLE HE CAME ACROSS IT WAS
NEVER ABOUT HIM.
IT WAS ALWAYS ABOUT MOLDING AND
GROOMING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
LEADERS.
I WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE
BEFORE YOU.
IF IT WASN'T FOR JOB QUITE.
NEARLY EVERY LEADER IN THE CITY
OF ALL IN PARK CAME TO HIM. FOR
ADVICE AND GUIDANCE.
AND HE ALWAYS WAS WILLING TO
GIVE OF HIS TIME.
JACK WAS A DEVOTED FATHER TO
JACKIE AND CHANCE DOWN.
AND A HUSBAND. TO AT THE WHITE.
WHO WE CALL GRANDMA AT NOW?
I RESPECTED HIM EQUALLY TO MY
FATHER.
MY DAD DID IN MY ENSURING THAT
SPACE.
BECAUSE WE ALL LOVED HIM.
WE BECAME FAMILY TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE FAMILY
FOR ALLOWING ME. TO SHARE IN THE
LOVE OF THIS GREAT MAN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
REMEMBRANCE SUCH A GREAT LEADER
AND PUBLIC SERVANT I ASK FOR
YOUR LOVE AND RESPECT. FOR JACK
THE WHITE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HIS NAME
FORWARDS WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
SENATE ADJOURNED TODAY ALSO IN
MEMORY OF A CONSTITUENT OF MINE.
CALIFORNIA CAPTAIN STACY
HAMILTON.
STACEY TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY --
DURING AN OFF DUTY CAR ACCIDENT
JUNE EIGHTH AND IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE AND TWO TEENAGE SONS.
CAPTAIN HAMILTON BEGAN HIS
CAREER WITH CAL FIRE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX AFTER SERVING
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR SERVICE.
IN TWENTY TEN HE WAS ASSIGNED TO
THIS YEAR TRAINING CENTER FOR
SURE TRAINING PROGRAM RETRAIN
INMATES FOR MORE THAN FOUR YEARS.
MOST RECENTLY SERVED AS THE AIR.
TACTICAL GROUP SUPERVISOR AT THE
COLUMBIA AIR ATTACK BASES NEAR
THE SIERRA NEVADA FOOTHILLS INTO
WOLLEMI COUNTY WHERE HE WAS
DESCRIBED AS EXTREMELY TALENTED
A GREAT FRIEND MENTOR IN PERSON.
MEMBERS -- PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF CAPTAIN
STACY HAMILTON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE TO MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED ARCHIE
STACEY.
MEMBERS WE ARE SENATE MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS ARE THERE ANY
FURTHER ADJOURNED A MEMORIES
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MADAM PRO TEM THE DESK IS CLEAR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HI AS
FOLKS OR HAPPEN TO GET OUT OF
HERE LET ME JUST MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW THAT WE ARE TAKING OUR
SENATE PHOTOGRAPH.
ON MONDAY SO IT BE GREAT IF
PEOPLE COULD BE AT THE IN THE-FLOOR ALL ON THE FLOOR ON TIME.
AND FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE
HERE I KNOW WE'RE GONNA LOOK
GREAT I HOPE OUR COLLEAGUES DO
AS WELL.
SO -- WE WILL RECONVENE MADAM
PRESIDENT ON MONDAY JUNE
SEVENTEENTH AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY WILL BE.
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND EVERYONE